[Musique]
avec vous Hélène frappe bien sûr bonjour
Hélène Bondy à Pauline à la une de la
presse Hélène la victoire sur le fil
donc de Lula face à Jaya bolsonaro à la
présidentielle brésilienne
une nouvelle fois il y va à nouveau
titre ce matin audio le quotidien de Rio
salut la victoire du candidat des partis
des travailleurs à l'issue de ce qu'ils
présentent comme l'une des élections les
plus féroces de ces dernières années
Lola élu pour la troisième fois faut il
y a de San Paolo évoque le second tour
le plus serré de l'histoire du Brésil et
l'accueil positif à l'étranger de cette
nouvelle victoire de l'ancien métallo
Lula accueille positif favorable
notamment au Portugal ou le journal ou
pour l'écho exprime sa satisfaction de
voir le Brésil choisir la démocratie en
ayant le la une nouvelle fois
de retour à la présidence 12 ans après
son deuxième mandat dans un pays divisé
au milieu divisé en deux souligne Audi a
lieu de noter siège qui est un autre
quotidien portugais qui rappelle en
effet qu'entre temps lola a été arrêté
en 2018 dans le cadre de l'opération
anticorption avant d'être libéré il y a
moins de trois ans novembre 2019 après
580 jours de prison la division du
Brésil qui est évoquée également ce
matin par le quotidien espagnol et le
païs qui cite la réaction du nouveau
président brésilien à son élection on a
tenté de m'enterrer vivant mais je suis
toujours là alors on retourne dans la
presse brésilienne Hélène maintenant qui
accueille cette victoire avec un certain
soulagement et de tendance plutôt
conservatrice le magazine wejja qui est
une référence de la presse brésilienne
estime pourtant que ce retour de Lula se
mettent au Brésil je cite d'échapper au
suicide politique et de revenir à la
démocratie une démocratie que le projet
du président sortangère bolsonaro aurait
pu détruire selon l'hebdo même son de
cloche du côté de la folle sympa qui
voit dans cette alternance la
démonstration de la solidité de la
démocratie brésilienne et dans la
victoire de Lula une réaction elle est
lent autoritaire aux transversales à
l'inépé l'inefficacité et à la
désinvolture de bolsonaro la majorité de
l'électorat a rejeté un gouvernement qui
s'est avéré dès le début conflictuel
inhumain et effroyablement destructeur
et s'estime aussi ou je t'adore qui juge
dans moi que la victoire de Lula est
loin de représenter une solution pour le
Brésil et que le président élu à le
devoir désormais de calmer les esprits
lola a une chance de racheter le Brésil
mais pour cela il va devoir agir comme
le chef d'un front élargit d'un front
pluriel et nous comme le chef d'une
faction mettant garde au groupe en
évoquant les défis gigantesques qui
attendent le Brésil et les innombrables
doutes qui planent sur ce troisième
mandat de Londres voilà pour la presse
locale quelle réaction à l'étranger
alors à l'image de nombreux quotidiens
étrangers de Financial Time ça revient
sur le parcours hors norme de Lula dont
la victoire constitue je cite l'ultime
triomphe d'une vie passée à combattre
l'adversité Lula dont le parcours de
cireurs de chaussures au plus haute
fonction de l'état inspiré des millions
de Brésiliens dans un pays profondément
inégalitaire malgré la victoire de Lola
et le païs toujours estime que les
signaux d'alerte restent toujours allumé
au Brésil et que l'extrémisme
anti-démocratique incarnée par Lula a
non seulement pris des proportions
gigantesque mais également poussé encore
un peu plus vers la droite la droite
dite modérée enfin en Allemagne le
Frankfurter alguemines saitum
s'interroge sur la réaction dans les
jours les heures qui viennent de
bolsonaro et de son camp durant ce
mandat rappelle le quotidien bol
solarois systématiquement saper la
confiance dans les institutions et
critiquer à plusieurs reprises les
autorités et le système électoral et
puis pour être tout à fait complet
Hélène quelques dessins de presse ouais
la victoire de Lula sur le fil inspiré
ce dessin au Cuba Vimard qui montre Lula
devant son un tout petit cheveux sont
rivales jaillir belsonaro Lula nouveau
président on l'a évoqué d'un pays plus
divisé que jamais et dont le poids
écrasant désormais sur ses épaules un
dessin d'une néerlandais Martens
voltoring Lola représentait aussi en
dans le destin du français placide avec
une allusion évidemment au feu
dévastateurs qui ont ravagé l'Amazonie
durant le mandat de bolsonaro bolsonaro
convoite ici en fâcheuse posture face au
nouveau capitaine slessin oui
qui s'apprête à tirer un penalty
douloureux
autre dessin d'un dessinateur cubain
celui-ci est signé Oswald et il montre
cette fois Jaillard bolsonaro tenant
dans ses mains la citrouille grimaçante
de gervolsonaro halloween oblige